so we have with us shawn o'sullivan and
uh first i'll give you a little
background on the on the khan academy
connection uh yes about three years ago
we get an email from you
saying that you wanted to help us
and we're like
okay and and so you show up and then you
you know we spent a more is that 277
castro i think we were probably what a
five-person organization then
maybe three-person organization at the
time uh you spend a half an hour with
not a half a day with me and shot new
and uh you leave essentially
one of our biggest supporters ever uh so
you know thank you and that was a big
vote of confidence in what we've done
and it was that you know it was a phase
of the organization where
you know we didn't know what it would
become and and all the rest so that was
a you know
we well i i mean you were already so far
down the road it was obvious that uh you
were on to great things and uh here look
at the team you've got around you've
built an amazing set of products and
capabilities and affecting many millions
of people's lives it's something that uh
anyone is lucky uh whether you're
working here or supporting con you know
you're lucky to be a part of such a
great social movement
for good
yeah no i i
i knock on wood every morning
so so let me introduce everyone to you
so you have
there are actually several claims to
fame that i knew about you before but
then this morning i started doing some
research about you and you have lived a
full life
so
i i guess right now you're most famous
especially in ireland for being on the
on the dragon's den which is essentially
like the the shark tank
of ireland yep that's right
you're one of these it's actually the
third most popular show in ireland after
like the late late show and
the news so it's super like nobody
really knows the shark tank here but uh
you know it's i don't know it's probably
the 50th or 100th most popular show in
in america i don't know but in ireland
you know i can't walk down the street
without people uh you know uh giving you
a bit or giving you a business plan or
and you have to be all right
and it's one of these premises where
it's a bunch of investors and they have
to pitch and you'll all have like money
on your coffee table
yes yes
that's the show and we have some footage
of it
who is prepared to enter the dragon's
den
inside could be the money to turn
business dreams into reality
but only the bravest and the best can
tame the dragons who guard the prize
those dragons are five of the country's
most wealthy and successful business
people
and the budding entrepreneurs who dare
to face them in the den need to convince
them to invest in their dreams
the dragons all know what it takes to be
successful in the fiercely competitive
world of business having built their
companies the hard way
technology pioneer sean o'sullivan runs
a vego a world-leading transportation
software company headquartered in cork
and operating globally while investing
millions in startup businesses my vision
is to make style and fashion with
wonderful music engineering and this is
it it's called egg guitars
the electric guitar industry has been
dominated by products which have not
been innovative for 50 years
i'm conscious of style
i like to wear clothes that represent
what i stand for and so do all my
generation this is what they want it's
new it's cool it's highly functional and
they will love it
i
i'm doing for guitars what steve jobs
has done for phones you know one of my
fellow dragons was in a rock band
rockstar with an owned recording studios
as well so he was only the piano player
and it speaks french
if you google it was big in the 50s okay
i was born yeah but uh not before gavin
was born however
what's the market for guitars how many
sell a year yeah so
like this is approximately between the
states and europe you've got about a
million electric guitars per year
what is the
revenues that you're projecting i'm
aiming to sell 2000 guitars in the first
year at 160 euros per guitar so that's
working out at 320 000. i wanted to
retail at three four nine but i want to
bring that back to 299 after you know
i'm getting more efficient with
production and stuff like that
rob i think you're
potentially a really great entrepreneur
and i think you're probably going to
need more money to
to do this than the 35 000
so i'd like to give you a little more
money than you asked for and take a
little more equity than you asked for so
uh i propose to give you 50 000 euro for
25 percent equity
also
we have a hardware accelerator program
in china that takes uh designers like
yourself from anywhere around the world
puts them in
in situ in in the environment we can put
you into a program like that
and get you working directly with the
factories and getting more electronics
so these are all things that i'd love to
work with you on future uh generations
of products um you know if i was working
with you um i'd really like to work with
you but um 25 would you do anything
where you compare that back you know if
we hit targets to 20
um if you sell 2000 guitars in the first
year i'll
give up from 25 and down to 20 percent
okay yeah cool yeah don't do
great congratulations
a deal and a last minute reduction in
equity
now that's worth getting out of bed for
take it easy
take care good luck
was it him you were looking at oh yeah
because i didn't see the differentiation
in the product really at least predicted
the product is i mean the product's good
it's different it's absolutely different
sean that that sales model that he's
going to sell it to pay as much as you
think you feel the guitars worth i think
yeah
all right that's it that's rob o'reilly
and that deal closed and rob has
actually since come out with some
second generation of products so it
worked out well yeah it worked out this
is like a real thing because you see
this on tv shows you don't think yeah no
it's actually
a lot of times half the time the deal
doesn't uh go through
even after it seems like it goes through
in my case probably
they go through around 80 85 percent of
the time but some some of the other
dragons or sharks don't actually you
know they don't come to terms at the end
and so this is actually a venture that
you're you're still working on and yeah
you know it's it's they're producing you
know it's got some rave uh reviews it's
very unusual guitar uh it has several
unique features uh that uh you know has
a midi output uh as well as the sound
output it has
you know it's cut out in the center it
has a balanced beam it's got plectrum uh
you know it's it's it's a nicely
designed guitar yeah and we'll talk
about it because as we'll see that is
part of your your past
this is the music industry yes which
that's
invest in what you know exactly
so so we'll start at the beginning
because i mean obviously it's an
interesting
life so far you've had you you were born
in new york
yep you're
you're irish descent yeah new york city
irish descent you eventually end up back
in ireland but how did it start i was i
was reading about i mean you were one of
nine children
yes i was one of nine children so um i
was born in new york city i actually had
a
uh
you know a deadbeat dad actually so we
uh that's
my mother and my father got separated uh
when i was three and we were raised in
poverty in upstate new york uh on the
welfare system
and
uh so for
uh for five or six years my mom was
raising the nine kids who were all under
the age of ten i was
three
nine kids under the age of ten yeah at
one point but then we got older and
after uh
after uh you know six or seven years of
that she was able to get a job and and
uh you know we sort of worked our way
out of worked our way out of poverty
over the years
but that was the that was the start of
it you know it's new york state is not a
great place to be growing up poor
because the weather is actually quite
severe compared to california so you
know it could be you know with wind
chill or whatever minus 40 degrees and
so when we would uh
go to sleep at night uh you know in the
dead of winter we'd gather in one room
with a wood stove with the wood that we
cut down from trees ourselves uh and uh
i
just try to you know
all of us you know some sometimes a
couple people in one bed uh just the six
or seven
uh people say in in uh one room sleeping
with a wood stove yeah
it's probably different than how you
grew up
uh but maybe not
it wasn't that bad actually all right
and i mean and how did you know given
that start which is you know it's a hard
beginning um
how did you get into
i mean technology how did you get into
computers
which was kind of your first passion or
one of your first passions is that music
yeah so my first passion probably would
have been computers uh i
somehow
saw my older brother went to college and
he this was back in the day when they
still had punch cards and i saw some you
know some printouts of work that he was
doing uh as a computer science uh
program
uh himself
and um so i said wow i really i really
it was just fascinating it was really
appealing to me you know when you are
grow up poor you don't have that much
control over your environment and to
actually be able to control a computer
is an incredibly powerful thing you know
it does whatever you tell it to do you
know
and
you know that's that's really remarkable
so it was a way of getting some control
over uh
the situation and being able to develop
myself
um and support myself
and you even support even when you're in
high school yeah yeah actually my first
professional job programming was when i
was 14. so i
had learned some programming and
there was
for the in america for the poorest of
the poor there's a program called the
civilian employment training act i'm not
sure if it's still around
but they basically give you jobs uh
that are supposed to prepare you for a
long time career so
they gave me a job being a janitor in my
high school
and i i said well geez that's not the
greatest uh career potential uh and i
don't understand why it's a training act
if i don't really need that much
training uh to push a broom around or
vacuum cleaner or whatever in the first
place but i found a a
county
agency that was you know a couple miles
from my house
and so i i
asked the person who ran that agency if
i could just
have a job basically changing data tapes
or you know printing out things just
just to get uh started in
and then when he discovered i could
program and i could program better than
several of the other uh you know uh
programmers uh there were older uh you
know professionals that uh i ended up
getting started that way wow wow i
didn't even appreciate i mean this
wasn't that long ago this was like the
early 80s this is the yeah early 80s
early 80s that they would recommend for
a 14 year old to be the janitor it is
yeah like it's better than nothing
because you still get to you know it's a
minimum wage job but you still get some
you're working and you're contributing
to your family's you know um you know
your family situation so it's not a
terrible program although you know
they're they're obviously they could
have aimed a little higher than uh
janitor so i did work as a janitor and
as a as a uh
um you know uh groundskeeper and things
like that for maybe a year before i'd
found a way to get my self out of it and
and that i mean obviously you got that
that job and you kept developing it and
you you go to rensselaer yeah so i
i uh yeah i kind of into rensselaer
polytechnic institute
uh which is in troy new york the oldest
english-speaking uh engineering school
in the world um
uh continuously running or whatever
the
the the claim to fame is the the
inventor of the television the inventor
of the semiconductor uh process the
first microprocessor and all these other
you know the brooklyn bridge all those
other uh sort of things and and as a i
had been i grew up like an hour
southwest of there so i was always
hearing about you know how they were in
the mars lover rover project and all
this when i was growing up and i just
said wow that just sounds like the kind
of thing i want to do do really
impactful you know
amazing things so that's what got me
into engineering um
and
never looked back you know i think that
engineers have a disproportionate power
um in the planet to affect the world for
for in
massive ways so you know
i you know we were just talking about
this little earlier um that a lot of the
brightest students unfortunately choose
to
to major in areas which are basically
service industries like one-to-one
service industries like the brightest
kids in high school sometimes end up
choosing to become doctors or lawyers
and those are things that are one-to-one
service industries versus becoming an
engineer where you have the report you
know capability to affect you know
millions and billions of people's lives
with products that you design and
impacts that you have on the planet
which i've also been lucky uh to to have
been able to have been part of teams and
leading teams that have had those kinds
of changes over the years and and that's
you know your first experience coming
out of college and especially growing up
poor
um
it
you know i mean i i i didn't you know i
my background wasn't as dire as it was
but
not not that different as well but it
you know one of the things when you come
out of college is that fear of well do i
be an entrepreneur and kind of risk it
all or do i at least just go for the
middle class
you know pay the bills get a car
you went you went entrepreneurial are
you
yeah from the beginning days like
i mean that you know it's it's really
easy to go like you know living like a
from living like a college student where
you don't have any money you don't you
know don't have any possessions or
whatever to like living like an
entrepreneur which is safe
you haven't changed anything yeah you
don't have any money you're you know you
don't have any needs or things that
would prevent you from from doing it so
i was lucky enough i had worked my way
through college you know uh you know for
ibm and a couple of other uh smaller
tech companies well during summers and
whatnot so i was able to
know that i also i also knew before i
graduated college that i didn't really
want to work
for a large company because
i saw like you know ibm's great company
and everything but i saw some of the
best engineers
that i was working with in research
triangle park at one point north
carolina um that they they they were
working on this video phone project back
in 1984 or something
and uh and then ibm the company bought
rome rohm which is the key systems
phone provider for like a billion
dollars and so this
team of super dedicated engineers that
have been working like eight years on
this
amazing product just got x off because
of some big corporate decision that had
been made 10 levels above them and
they'd work their bones off to produce
this unbelievable
you know
you know break break groundbreaking
products and they never saw the light of
day and i said you know i'd rather not
have that happen to me i'd rather be
working in a smaller environment where i
can have
a lot more control over my destiny and
so that's why i chose to start a company
that's why i think it's always great to
work in it's in smaller organizations
that do have big big impact like like
like you have here at khan academy yeah
and that first it was map info this was
uh i mean you you it was kind of a
pioneering company you know now
everything you know google maps and you
have all these you know yeah so if
you've ever has anyone ever done this
has anyone ever typed an address into a
computer and seen a street map could you
can i see a show of hands if anyone's
done that before so we invented that you
know um and that was a long long time
ago
because i'm like
i'm approaching 50 like you know a
bullet train to to that wall over there
you know before you could say oompa
loompa
i'm going to be 50 years old
so um i like it was a long long time ago
30 years ago
that we we did this
and uh
and you know it was it was a big idea
back then and it pioneered and set the
groundwork for all the technology that
has since developed from it
um you know i have a total huge respect
for what you know that google's um
you know that that street uh street view
thing and and whatnot they've really uh
you know a lot of companies have done a
lot uh with the technology
but we we we pioneered it the first
million or so people that used street
mapping on computers were were uh you
know 99 of them were using map info
became a couple hundred million dollar
company became a public company uh it
was licensed by a lot of the bigger
companies to to do it but more
importantly
you know the thousands of
resellers and the thousands of local
countries that were using our product
digitized all the street maps using our
product or or made it available to their
customers using our product which sort
of set the groundwork for
all the mapping that that that happens
today you know so it's pretty cool and
that was that so that was my first
company i was there for seven years and
i was the president and uh chairman of
it for for then and then i then i left
and you let you know it goes public and
you leave and you know the classic
silicon valley thing is oh you know i've
had one exit let me go do my next one or
let me become a partner at a vc firm or
yeah you start a rock band
yeah yeah
that was that was an
unconventional choice i think i've made
i've made several unconventional choices
i was listening earlier this morning to
love his pain oh my god so that's uh
that's from our first uh first uh ep
five song ep
um uh some
some uh you know copyright violators put
it up onto the internet which you were
happy about i was it was funny because i
saw it
the name of the band was janet speaks
french janet speaks french janet speaks
french uh you actually got i mean you
got on the radio yeah we are like
40 and like you know 80 radio stations
top 40 yeah yeah and we were uh but you
know 80 radio stations in the united
states is 2800 radio stations or
whatever so it's like no none of you
would have heard it uh if you were even
alive back in 1990
or whenever it was there
yeah and and i mean and and that i mean
what was going through your mind
obviously music was a love of yours
you had i you know you i guess you were
comfortable at this point financially
actually i wasn't quite comfortable at
that point because the the company was
in the registration process but it
hadn't actually gone public at that
point so oh wow um
so for a while i was just doing it uh
and you know that was all right like i i
don't live like in a really uh
extravagant way i don't need that much
money because you know it it always uh
you know it's good grounding to remember
where you came from because you could be
right back there any time you know you
never know what was uh in front of you
but uh
uh yeah so i i've never needed that much
to to get by so being a struggling rock
musician wasn't that big of an
adjustment uh for me and you do that for
how many years are you two years
actually two years and then i started a
technology company an internet company
it was
1995 or something
end of 1995 and so that was back when
netscape uh wasn't called netscape it
was called mosaic communications and
probably none of you even heard of
netscape even
we hire people older than 16. okay good
forget who i'm talking to an engineering
crowd how many of you are engineers uh
out there a handful kind of half a
little bit used to be very good that's
very good
so um so
yeah so um yeah so uh and we came up
with this concept
of you know network services over the
internet and software for inside the
internet uh which we then called cloud
computing you know so we came up with
that term i co-coined that term myself
and george vavaloro from compact
computer uh we should take pause there
yeah coined cloud computing yeah
there you go yeah yeah
yeah
um and and love is pain
it's not my favorite song actually
so you'd have to probably go to the
second album before you hit my favorites
but there's um what's what's good on
that now's um it isn't love that's
probably why it isn't love you were
going through some some some hard times
yeah absolutely
i was not talking about
and so you start the next company and
and and that was another
uh the next was that i was calling that
centric that central and then and and
that grew to like say 10 million in
sales it wasn't it wasn't a huge thing
um
and it got sold off basically in pieces
to cisco uh or somebody else i can't
even remember it's like i blocked that
whole part of my it wasn't it wasn't the
late night it wasn't a great success
at all i mean the investors like myself
that invested in it didn't make their
money back on it so it's a lesson in
life and then it was in and maybe i'm
skipping but this is i found this
fascinating i didn't know about this i
mean we've known each other for three
years but i didn't know this whole
chapter in your life you then go to iraq
no actually then i became a filmmaker
then you became a oh yeah you went to
film school
you became a filmmaker yeah so i went to
uh usc film school uh
in in la
which is awesome
and uh i was making films i made a you
know like a hundred films in five years
uh but it sounds like me i just kind of
yeah
yeah but like here's a lot better well
like the little little like three minute
videos and you know music videos and you
know lots of other things like that but
i was looking for a project um and the
iraq war was about to start in 2003
2003 yeah yeah so yeah so it was march
2003 when i finally i was started
working on trying to get into iraq and
get permission to get into iraq
in uh the end of 2002
um while it's because you saw the war
was coming the drought were yeah all
these protests all over you know new
york la i went and filmed all that and
then i got myself in with a peace
activist group called the christian
peacemaking team which just uh i was
just going to be documenting their uh
their struggles
and they
were allowed into iraq under the saddam
regime and so i went in there and uh it
was i was in iraq when the you know
when uh
in baghdad when uh what was it called
shankana uh yeah you know uh began and
it was actually quite an amazing time
to be there and to see it both both pre
and post
but as a filmmaker
you know i i also you know
as you do is when you go into
dictatorian regimes they they have um
followers called um
oh geez i'm forgetting everything
uh
minders yeah but the minders yeah oh
yeah that's what they're called yeah
minders thank you very much so they have
government like the
infra industry of information or uh
i'm forgetting i'm forgetting what the
uh what the name of the ministry of
information was but anyway the ministry
of information uh uh
would attach a minder to you to make
sure you didn't take photos of anything
you're not supposed to take photos of
because they only want to they will take
you to a place where you know maybe a
a bomb
went wrong or they
they claim obama went the wrong way or
they'll take you to hospitals and show
you pictures of women and children but
they won't actually let you photograph
anything else
so uh so i was ejected from the country
because i've never taken very well to to
rule rules so
um and so
that's where i met my wife actually she
was uh she was just also a rule breaker
she was uh
she was uh arrested by the syrians when
she was trying to cross the
uh river into iraq you know illegally
still zombing in uh so
so uh but she was in jordan and then
then when the wall or when baghdad fell
um the
the the border fell and we were able to
go uh back into the country and so i was
there for the next 18 months or so
wow i mean this is like you can make a
movie like i'm already imagining like
the casting for yeah i mean yeah that's
you're moving the cast is me yeah well
i'll think about that
i have some ideas but i'll tell you
the uh and so then and then you go back
into i mean this is that's and i was
even reading i mean one of your partners
in this
yeah mohamed also probably is that where
your friends yeah so i started i worked
a little bit for cnn and reuters and
just doing a lot of freelance
work at that point
and then uh after
a while i got fed up with
uh the u.s
government's ability to execute you know
they were just really in a you know they
couldn't get anything done
it didn't seem so
uh so i started a humanitarian
organization called jumpstart
international and we went in and we
cleaned up a whole bunch of uh we
employed
3 500 people in the end who started with
just
myself and 30 guys and then we grew it
up over you know
over the time
uh to about 3 500 people so we were
actually the largest humanitarian
organization after the u.n
pulled out uh pretty early um
uh you know they were they were bombed
and and whatnot so
in in and this is this is during the war
what time period is this this is uh well
actually there was a sort of a post-war
period right uh
which was from say around april may of
2003
to when the civil war started which was
uh april of 2004. i see so i was
i you were kicked out you went back you
and then you come back yeah i come i
came back almost immediately yeah um you
know because baghdad just lasted for
another nine days or something like that
before it fell or five days or something
and then
and then i went back and then i was
running this humanitarian organization
and then the civil war
and i built that up and the civil war
started in april of 2004 and then i was
still there you know for until the end
of that year
wow and and your partner
yeah my co-founder of jumpstart was
mohamed al-safar who's in iraqi and he
was uh he was assassinated
um
because we used to we were we were just
driving around all the time uh
you know just us
visiting all the projects so we would
have 80 projects at a time
um you know hospitals and uh you know
universities and uh we'd be cleaning up
or taking down skyscrapers that were
bombed or burned uh
and then just uh
it was just a big manpower and
engineering sort of effort to try to
clean up the city and and re
you know we built a lot of housing
thousands of homes i mean you must have
seen some
yeah so
yeah so so uh both during the war and
you know the civil war is actually the
worst part if you think about american
history the civil war is
where more americans have ever uh have
died i'm sure right because many factors
half a million yeah um yeah i mean you
have you'd have it with the smaller
there would be 200 250 000 or something
like that would die versus uh you know
in world war ii over six years or
something i think we lost a million
people or less than that i you know so
so the civil american civil war is the
worst in iraq it's the exact same thing
you know with uh when that started in
april 2004 all the way until recently
you know it's uh it's been the bloodiest
sort of people and y'all were inserting
yourselves in kind of the i mean just
where the
yeah there's carnage and where there's
yeah so like we would clean up after a
terrorist bombing you know and there'd
be body parts and we'd we'd be i'd be
stepping over body parts or stepping on
them or clean you know cleaning up uh
things a lot of my uh workers would be
injured um and i was just living in the
i wasn't living in the green zone which
is the american occupied or the you know
what coalition occupied territory i was
living in
you know the red zone the other area the
other parts of the city so um so we
would just go around all the time that i
mean i guess there's a question you know
what was driving you to do like
i was frustrated you know i mean what
what what does any entrepreneur you know
feel like you know when you see a market
that's not being served when you when
you when you just like this needs to
happen you know like it's so stupid that
the work wasn't getting done but you
didn't think i mean especially as a you
know
american or someone who looks your
especially as american but but you know
that would be in the green zone where
you're afraid i mean i mean you could be
a target yeah yeah you abducted you sure
so sure but you know but there were
americans there risking their lives they
had suits and
you know guns and whatnot you know but
why shouldn't an american who's unarmed
you know be out there
risking their life you know for the same
uh for the same cause you know to
hopefully liberate the the country and
set them on their their course and leave
them alone
um but you know it's it's uh
you know i i was in danger were there a
lot of folks like this i mean there
weren't many yeah because i mean my
impression
just through the news and whatever else
is that you had the green zone that's
where the civilian the the western
civilians lived and every now and then
they might with a huge military escort
kind of making excursion outside of the
the green zone so yeah i mean were there
now there's actually usa today called me
one point i think was around september
2004
and they said we think you're the last
we think you're the last one there
no the christian peacemaking team who i
kept in contact with uh they're still
around and then
then they got you know they
got kidnapped and tortured and some of
them killed as well so like there were
there were not that many people and most
of
them i mean i'm just trying on like i i
mean it's admirable and it's amazing to
kind of go in and do this stuff and
but especially you know you're like the
last one even the people who are turning
off the lights when you when you're
right they're getting abducted getting
tortured no i i had probably most of
most of the people i knew probably got
either kidnapped or but i mean in your
mind did you view this as a rational
i mean weren't you afraid weren't you
you know there's being brave and that
there's
yeah well actually what finally sent me
from the country
uh and when i did leave is because i
thought that actually and i i'm not that
i'm not that uh
you know i'm not that uh religious of a
person but uh what finally sent me for
the country is i was blinded in my left
eye and i had cancer
and that that those two indicators
if it was just the cancer by itself
actually and if you look closely at
they actually cut out an inch
and a two inch uh patch it just kept
getting worse and i couldn't uh you know
and i and actually the the u.s uh what
was your family
that was very good they didn't even
charge me anything
and then
and then i went blind in my left eye and
that was because i got some infection
and then the iraqi doctor that i went to
gave me a steroid but it was a viral
infection and so a steroid on a virus it
makes it a super virus and it basically
ate my eye
and so it ate the skin off my eye and i
didn't have any skin on my eye
and uh it was it was bad yeah at that
point i said you know god is trying to
give me a message because in irish
actually o'sullivan o'sullivan means um
the one-eyed giant or something so so uh
so there i was with one eye left and
and actually amazingly you know i i got
i got a treatment for it afterwards
and you know they they take your blood
and uh they make some sort of special
potion out of your blood and it's it's
you can put it into your eye and my eye
grew back
and my vision got better
than
it was before so
so so actually my vision is now better
but it will that it was free being eaten
by steroid induced virus
by eating virus if you have trouble i
recommend going to iraq
i
set you up with this iraqi doctor
yeah i didn't actually i didn't even i
mean i didn't even know half of this
stuff i i thought i'd done my
that this is mind-blowing yeah i want to
talk more
we
at the end at the end of it i said you
know what
i'm getting enough messages here i mean
everybody's telling me i mean freaking
uh nbc news followed me around for a day
to do my obituary you know so like
seriously yeah i didn't they didn't tell
me like the guy who wants to yeah the
guy who was doing it no no no no i
didn't want to die i i didn't want him
it looks like someone who almost has a
you know like the guy in world war one
who always you know like americans had
to do something and it was very very
very frustrating to just go and do do do
you know to let the situation uh
be what it was and i'm proud of america
actually
you know i i think americans try to do
the most incredible things um for the
planet
their intent what separates their intent
and their execution sometimes is is
awful you know and uh you know and
everyone says oh yeah there was some ill
intent in all this and yeah maybe a
little bit but it was mostly just
misconceived in in in my view and so
like to just let that go
you know it was it was speaking to my
core that i needed to do something and i
was in a place to do something i had
some money i actually
gave you know i started this it started
it myself and then i got some u.n
funding and some some some other funding
to keep it was your wife with you
because she yeah she was well she's she
was you know she she's a uh she was a
war reporter so
so she's uh a little bit accustomed to
it but it was time for both of us to get
out so we we got married and then uh and
i was actually then i i was working in
the gaza strip we've built a
university uh you know gaza polytechnic
um
and uh and i was on that trip
you know we got married uh on new year's
eve and nine months and seven days later
uh charlotte our first daughter was born
and so i think that's god's other signal
uh was that uh
you know i was not supposed to be in war
zones anymore uh so i
uh you know when i i was in the gaza
strip when i found out my wife was
pregnant and that was basically at the
end of it i i said screw it i'm not
going to do this anymore so
so i i didn't and now i've i've i've
gone back and i throw myself at the
technology and technology and then you
go back to ireland why ireland as
opposed to
i was using my irish passport when i was
going in and around uh in the green zone
and you know to get into the green zone
and
um as opposed to your why the irish
american president i was under the
pretense that that uh that iraqi arabic
speakers couldn't tell the difference
between
irish uh sounding accents and american
sounding accents right and actually um
and it would just it would just be
better if you were kind of abducted with
an irish passport as an american
absolutely
yeah absolutely it would be better the
admission uh fee to get in for a visa is
like one tenth as much if you have your
irish passport versus if you have your
american passport a hundred dollars or
something to get him as an american or
five dollars and so then when you go
back to ireland you uh i guess because
you were using the passport you started
to feel i guess you always kept some
type of a joint citizenship or yeah i
had uh
through my grandparents i had irish
citizenship so anyway so i started a
company in ireland and now you know i
live the quality of life in ireland it's
great
you know uh i you know i love it's it's
great being there and uh we've just sort
of started a company that i'm um a
couple of companies that i'm on mind you
start a couple companies and even in
your current sos ventures y'all back
some of them
fairly well known yeah so hero oh yeah
well yeah so yeah guitar hero would have
would have been a great win for us
there's you know a backed uh
you know pretty heavily a company called
netflix yes we've heard of it yes i've
done yeah it's done well
um and uh you know a number like we have
about 160 companies in the portfolio
lead motion was one of the ones i was
just talking about there's a
great big one that we were the first vc
in on that as well that's a recent one
but there's you know and so this week in
san francisco we're actually launching
20 different companies on monday we
launched 10 from accelerator and today
later today we're launching the leap
accelerator um program in uh in san
francisco with 10 new companies
so so so we do a lot uh and i manage a
couple hundred million dollar uh fund
and we we believe in accelerating
companies you know we're the accelerator
vc
so we we do a lot uh to try to start as
many
good companies as we can because you
know ultimately you can try to you can
try to go in and you can try to you know
change people's lives by you know
building a house or something like that
but if you can change change their lives
by for example enabling cloud computing
or enabling you know street mapping on
computers or any of these new
technologies that were that were we're
launching you know these are really
transforming tens of millions or if not
more
of people's lives this is what i was
speaking to you know in terms of the the
disproportionate power that engineers
have to
impact
you know the quality of life of mankind
and we can you know that that's
the most impact you can have as a person
so even as a venture capitalist you know
that's what i look to you know is this
adding good to the planet to do this and
what you're doing in khan academy um you
know it was a you know five million
dollar commitment that we made which is
a
reasonable size commitment it's huge for
i mean it's it's it continues to be one
of our largest gifts ever uh but
especially at that phase of the
organization it was a it was a big deal
for us well thank you but but you know i
i feel honored that uh you know to be a
part of a part of your success because
what you're doing is you know so
transformative and potentially so
transformative
i know you're only part of the way there
so none of you engineers need to rest on
your laurels
because it's a lot more a lot more that
needs to be done but um
uh yeah but uh you know life is like
that you know you try to get up every
day and do something you know amazing um
and uh you know try to make the world a
better place that's all that's all the
guiding philosophy is about it and i
mean what's been incredible obviously
you helped support us but you've also
turned into something of an advisor and
you've been driving some pretty neat
initiatives in ireland that we're
actually hoping to eventually
yeah so i'm running a little petri dish
and we've got this thing going i don't
know if sal or any of the gang has
talked about it called mathletes
um
and it's an experiment that we try and
it is super cool it is just super cool i
was just looking over some of the stats
this morning
and uh you know we launched we came up
with this idea
um
to to try to duplicate the
the passion that people have about
athletics
and the pride that people have about
their school or their their their you
know individual performance
trying to have people be
as dedicated to their schools through
mathletics
as they would to athletics and
and this is something that you know it
seems like it's working you know it's
the early days but uh
in uh
just the age range that we're talking
about uh from 11 to 15
um the evidently by running this
mathletes competition over two and a
half months the the web traffic for khan
academy is something like three and a
half times as many for all of ireland
for all of ireland y'all we're
essentially just getting started these
last few months yeah and so we launched
the idea you know one and a half percent
of all the kids in ireland in that age
range are now competing in in athletes
um if you did that across the united
states i think it would be like 70 000
70 000 schools would be competing
and it's competing at a you know with
uh at a very very very significant level
like
they're they're the top one percent of
kids in the last two and a half months
have spent i don't know we just looked
at the stats it was 20 something hundred
twenty seven minutes or something like
that yeah so minutes of studying
several two months in just two months
several grade levels of math you know in
just two and a half months now that's
the top one percent but if you take it
to the top five percent it's not
10
they've done several grade levels of of
math in in you know with the 700 minutes
or 580 minutes it's really turned into a
national thing the prime ministers yeah
it was all the the anti-ship which is
the the irish for uh prime minister it's
a ministerial form of government rather
than the president in ireland doesn't uh
is is not the same as the president here
so so the anti-shick is the head of the
government
and um so he's given away the athletes
prizes we have little trophies that he
gives that have been given to the
schools for their uh competition it
started in february um the final the
finals and it's and it works out like
you know like the ncaas sort of thing
where there's a whole you know
press coverage and there's leaderboards
that go out every week people know where
their schools are on the leaderboards on
a county level on a regional level and
on a national level and so there's a
tremendous amount of pride that people
are taking in their accomplishments and
the accomplishments of their school and
the teachers are getting sucked into
this
because they're passionate about it and
because they're
because it's exciting and because the
kids are excited
and so it's potentially a really really
really interesting way
of
you know we've seen that um
you know something like 350 percent
uh you know
the number of the number of people
that are participating in ireland
is only
doubled even though it's just this age
age range but the on khan academy now
but the
the
the engagement
is like four times
um so
so the the number of page views and the
number of time so if if we can duplicate
that
for the world you know or for the united
states
then you're talking about a lot of
impacts yeah and we're i'm super excited
about this and another thing i'm excited
about is there's been this fallacy that
women aren't good at math
and uh this proves you know we we've got
exactly 50 50 you know uh gender split
uh for the top performing uh athletes in
the in the uh in the country and then
even at the national competition which
is taking place next saturday um
this there is a slight discrepancy but
we don't know if there's gender bias in
the in how parents
we don't know we have to look at the
data a little bit more but it's still
incredibly similar it's 54 to 46 uh boys
to girls at the at the national level
which when you think about your day sal
when you were in math competitions how
many women were in the competitions
versus men
there weren't many there were
it's awful so we need to you know
as they say women hold up half the sky
so you know we have to uh we have to use
all of our talent all of our people to
to advance
the planet and more women should become
you know more more technically capable
yeah awesome well thank you i mean i
could go on for hours because actually
on each of this yeah i actually have a
million questions about iraq as well but
anyway i mean thank you so much this was
a a bigger treat than i even expected
the more i got to even know you who i've
known for three years but uh the more
your background my respect for you has
gone you know to even a whole other
level and so thank you for being an
early supporter and and continuing to do
incredible things and pushing us into
the direction frankly we should be going
in which is getting more community
building and more people to kind of
really feel invested in in learning yeah
we're all we're all learning here and so
uh you know each day is a each day is a
joy if we just take it that way we don't
know what's what the future is we can't
predict what the future is but we can we
can measure we can go in a lean way and
we can adapt our course on the way and
hopefully some of the learnings we're
doing in our little petri dish in
ireland can apply to
the overall mission which i love about
what khan academy is doing so great
thank you thanks so much
you